inauguration day in washington dc
is often bitter cold but this is the
first year that it's also freezing in
hell
yes today donald trump will be sworn in
and on monday
he will move into the white house
continuing his long tradition
of evicting black families here
by the nation's capital it's gray and
overcast
yes the sun just one more of the many
big stars that refuse
to show up for this event look at this
inspiring mass of overweight over aged
predominantly white humanity
nothing but roseanne's and fieri's as
far as the eye can see
yes if a walmart could vomit this
this is like a pickup joint for seniors
last time i saw this much white hair
madonna was getting out of a limo
without panties
as you can see there is incredible
secret service and police presence
it takes a lot of people to make sure
that melania doesn't run away
she's pretty awesome did you see those
naked pictures of phil i didn't know
on the internet oh my god well let's
just say
they should call her laura no bush
because she saves her interestingly uh
donald trump has such a bad reputation
with women even the bible he's supposed
to put his hand
on has just filed a restraining order
might as well make some money off of
these idiots here we go
who needs tickets okay i got um i have a
couple of tickets in the anti-semitic
section
but i think i can get you an upgrade
into the anti-muslim section
there we see former president bill
clinton here
bill clinton a stark reminder of a more
dignified
genteel administration when vaginas were
probed by cigar
not by hand now coming up to the
standard the trump sons
also known as the less motivated
are menendez brothers for a trump
residency absolutely so what do you do
for fun besides drawing devil horns on
nancy pelosi
hola you're a latino for trump yes no so
let me ask you in your language out of
respect
i have a lot in common with trump
actually you know yeah the only
difference is the hand up my ass isn't
vladimir putin
because because he is a puppet
of course health care is an issue of
great importance to trump supporters
as many of them have a pre-existing
mental condition
health care crap right yeah obamacare
it was designed to be difficult i know
that's the way it is
and there's an owner of a small business
this must have killed you you probably
were forced to lay off so many of the
employees in your meth lab
now look what i have here i'm selling
the life-size replica
of the bible donald trump is being sworn
in on put your hand next to it
see see how it makes your hands look big
have another hat let's um let's update
the slogans okay that's for you
america gonna great yes and then for you
how about it's home of the brave not
homo of the battery
and for you of course hey [ __ ] bring me
a course
there we go and right here enjoy sir
i have no idea what's going on
check it out right now i'm here talking
to uh
these guys they call themselves bikers
for trump
yes and i'm going to take a wild guess
that those aren't exercise bikes
okay sir can you tell me why you voted
for trump in three hateful words or less
i am tired that's good
my pence will take the vice presidential
oath of office
administered by supreme court justice
clarence thomas
in what will be the closest pence has
ever stood to a black man
and look at our vice president he's
amazing he is such a beautiful man
come on honestly mike pence is so
uptight he has to take a roofie to
masturbate
now the trump supporters aren't as lame
as i want them to be
so i have to figure out it's just going
to take a second
liberals okay conservatives disagree on
so much it seems
but i want to bring them together now we
all agree on betty white right
yes wouldn't you say that betty white
rules yes would you repeat that
betty white let me write rules exactly
thank you very much
yes let's say it betty my rules
rules white rules
for msnbc this is triumphant
trump being sworn in as president right
now
millions of americans are peeing in
their pants
ironically this only serves to
strengthen trump's erection the 45th
president of the united states of
america
donald j trump
this american carnage stops
right here and stops
right now what a powerful speech it was
you liked it
it's fantastic i love the reverent nod
to fdr when trump declared that the only
thing we have to fear is fear itself
and also muslims mexicans most of the
middle east
all of africa except south africa uh
buzzfeed
access hollywood chemtrails lizard
people
undercover cops posing as hookers
undercover dudes posing as lady hookers
germs snakes saturday night live and uh
backstabbing bruce springsteen cover
back the parade is wrapping up it's been
a contentious day but i wanted people on
both sides to come together and have an
intelligent
conversation about the next four years
what do you think
will it be foreign policy or the economy
that would take priority
in president trump's
oh god i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm just not
used to saying it
you know it's it's the first day it
takes a little getting used to
okay so we're fine we're fine given the
problems that have already happened
with taiwan will foreign policy be
president trump's curse
okay surely one of you has an opinion on
this okay now we're talking about the
first hundred days anybody well i think
he was elected because of the economy
but okay fair enough
ironically president trump
okay okay we got this all right i get it
i get okay
[Applause]
let's all be positive and look forward
to the next four years
with president trump
[Applause]
you